the Joe Rogan experience did you see
that video of I don't know if the girls
from China or from Japan it's a turned
out to be fake but she's snowboarding
and behind her you see a bear running
yeah I did see that video yeah yeah is
that possible
it's not the videos fake where he's not
in Japan good question I'm not sure if
it's Japan isn't it might be China I did
see they they exist in Japan as well
right they do I believe so can you Jamie
I'm sorry I'm double Google asking you
yeah bring you one yeah it's a fun video
to watch so she was oblivious camera I
don't think it's real I think someone
just did some cool [ __ ] with CGI
but it looks pretty good yeah it looks
yeah it looks like if it was in a movie
like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] because the girls
got headphones on she's [ __ ] rocking
now yeah this I go as well recently it
was India just Sprint's across the road
and how fast it was going see here it is
so it's really well made whoever did it
it's like she's got a GoPro yeah it's on
the ground and then as she's going down
the hill and her snowboard at a certain
point in time you looking to see a
[ __ ] bear and she has no idea she's
laughing and everything's cool and then
wants to turn to the side again yeah I
think you see the bear terrifying
there it is yeah yeah that's the second
one is where I'm skeptical because it
seems like this [ __ ] it looks pretty
good there it was pretty damn good
doesn't it that would be hard to do yeah
a bear just gave up at that point
yeah then that chick is flying I have
never snowboarded from what I've heard
from my friends when you snowboard yeah
you to break your head
feet go up in the air and your head goes
down yeah it's easy to break your head
this supposed to be Japan yeah I've got
that Tiger one tiger did you ever see
the one where the dudes I think he's in
India they're on a bike like a motorized
it's the one I'm talking the trackers
chasing the pine yeah yeah get some it
almost gets it does definitely chases
them too
yeah dude
that's hetra fine that is [ __ ]
horrific here we go here it is so these
guys are latest Tiger just going for it
almost got him almost got right about
then my Jews renlund right there is
wishing he had the cash for a bigger
engine that's right there right there is
when you oh my god what a killing
machine and what's so beautiful what a
[ __ ] up way to die from like the most
beautiful thing that you ever created
if a tiger wasn't a murderous horrific
predator that definitely eats people you
would look at and go it was in a movie
like Avatar something like that a tiger
doesn't even look like a real creature
it's so beautiful stunning no beautiful
creatures only beautiful and spectacular
and murderous terrifying chasing you on
a moped speed as well same with a bay
think they're gonna be slow but they can
run everyone way faster than people they
run fast in Usain Bolt didn't get away
from a bear and all they need is one
little ankle pick yeah we'll just get
that ankle woo you go flying in the air
I see at first they tear you apart came
across your footprints and we believe
that the bare footprints were fairly
fresh maybe maybe passed our set exact
track that we were on in West China
showing with your hand Howie was maybe
about this big oh [ __ ] ding got a patron
on the Instagram that's big dude you got
a video actually suspend Mastiffs as
well Tibet must have run a nuts to me
trying to attack me we're going and the
guy just steps in throws the stone you
don't see that bit yeah there you go um
that's a pretty good size that's not
that's not as big as I was thinking but
that's its front pool isn't it yeah I
think yeah I'm not a it's like the back
pool is almost like a human footprint
isn't it well the big brown bears they
have there's a photograph a famous
photograph of a woman who is a she's a
wildlife biologist they had tagged this
grizzly like to put a collar on it or
find its location or something like that
maybe do a test on it and she's holding
its foot up and it is literally like a
huge dinner plate the foot see if you
find that picture of God know what
biologist holds up yeah well I saw that
one actually use them
Grizzly's part yeah it is [ __ ] huge
the cruel is on it yeah it's like it's
wide as my chest that's what the the
Boris foot looks like and she's holy
look at the [ __ ] size you don't you
don't stunned it that can so crazy it's
so crazy that nature created that just a
clean up system for the [ __ ] woods
anything with a lamp
yeah anything that's [ __ ] around
places it shouldn't be you're having too
many babies who I smell I'm coming to
get them done dark bar and you're you're
out there with these things and you just
have a little tent and nowhere yeah and
no weapons and there's a three of you or
four of you there was three for the
first three weeks and then there was two
of us for four days then from then on it
was pretty much solo most of the way for
the first sort of half of the expedition
and then the second half was super
interactive opened it up people would
join in also we're gonna do about it
yeah it was burnt pretty big in in China
we'd have journalists we'd have Chinese
celebrities and then we walk with you
and they would track with us yeah there
was some time organized events where
it'd be rock climbing would be teaching
them out of belay off the cliff
[Applause]